I'm thinking of taking picnoginol to help the circulation in my legs where I have a lot of pain for martinella.
Supposedly this helps increase nitric oxide. Last week or so I thought you mentioned that those with
cancer should not take nitric oxide. Would it be okay to take picnoginol since it would be a natural
production of nitric oxide from the picnoginol? I would say that for a cancer patient to take
picnoginol would be just fine. I understand that you know the makers and the sellers of a product
like picnoginol might take a study and run with maybe one piece of a study and say oh it's so
great for helping nitric oxide production. You can look on picnoginol it probably says that it's an
antioxidant because of that and it's an anti-inflammatory. So then should I not take it because
it's an antioxidant picnoginol would be a very miter antioxidant and you have very miter player
in increasing nitric oxide. It's much more of a TH2 stimulator than it is anything. So it could
decrease chronic inflammation. So I'd say picnoginol is just fine. We used to use picnoginol with
line patients and the biggest reason why I liked picnoginol with line. So most people with line
were we treated were at an autoimmune phase of the line and taking TH2 stimulators. So you have
two sides of your immune system, your TH1 side and your TH2 side. Taking TH2 stimulators help decrease
inflammation. Your TH1 side is primarily pro-inflammatory. Your TH2 side is primary anti-inflammatory
and picnoginol is an anti-inflammatory TH2 stimulator from PineBark Extract. So I think you're just
fine. Take you picnoginol.